-Boo!
-[exclaims]
[chuckles] Hello, Freddie Mercury!
[chuckles] Hello, David Bowie
or Bow-wee or--
-Either's fine. I never knew myself.
-Hmm.
You come down for the show?
Yeah, yeah,
I come every year as it goes, yeah.
It's nice being a ghost,
'cause you don't have to wait for it
to come on TV.
You can be invisible, go in the tent
and watch it as it happens.
Exactly. And if you want to
get involved, just knock a cake over.
[chuckles] Bit of fun.
-You do that?
-Do you remember Sura?
-Oh, last year, with Dave?
-Yeah, that was me.
-[chuckling]
-Oh, very good! Very good.
-Hello, Elvis Presley.
-All right, guys?
-Have I missed anything?
-[Noel] No, it's about to start.
Oh, hello, Buddy Holly.
I'm Prue Leith.
Oh, sorry, you look just like
my mate Buddy Holly.
Stop messing about, boys,
and start the show.
Sorry, Buddy. I mean, Prue.
[all] Welcome to
The Great British Baking Show.
Hey-o!
[Matt] This time…
-[exclaims]
-…with places in the final up for grabs…
You want this so bad
it's eating you up inside.
[Matt] …the bakers must produce
impeccable patisserie…
We're certainly stepping outside
of the home-baking skills.
…with a multi-layered Signature…
[Crystelle] Oh, God! I feel like
I'm giving birth. [laughs]
…a fiendishly French Technical…
I ain't got a clue what's going on.
…and an epic five-hour Showstopper…
[Chigs exclaims]
…that pushes the bakers…
God, please don't fall.
[Chigs] Let's see how it fits.
…to breaking point.
[Chigs grunts in frustration]
Oh, my Lord! I don't think I can take
much more of this.
[opening theme music playing]
[Crystelle chuckling]
Clearly, the least capable baker.
Most likely to go out this week,
patisserie's not really my thing.
But enough of the negativity.
I just need to enjoy it,
'cause the worst that could happen is
I go out as a semi-finalist
and that's not too shabby.
-It's nice and quiet.
-Yeah, I know. [chuckles]
Eerily quiet.
[Giuseppe] I'm not surprised
I'm standing here.
I'm shocked
that I'm standing here. [chuckles]
I had to buy new clothes
because I didn't expect
to make it this far.
Of course it would be extremely exciting
to be in the final.
Patisserie Week. The tasting grade
should play to my strengths.
The "looking" grade, that's where
I need to hone my skills.
[Chigs] This week,
I do feel a bit out my depth.
[exhales]
In the practice tent, I made the mistake
of looking at the others' bakes.
It was like,
"Oops, what have I got myself into?"
Hello, bakers. Welcome back to the tent,
and congratulations
for reaching the semi-final.
For your semi-final Signature Challenge,
the judges would like you to bake
eight patisserie-style layered slices.
Your layered slices need to be identical,
and, when cut into,
they should hold their form,
displaying those beautiful layers.
The judges will be looking for
technically flawless, high-end bakes.
Basically, you just have to make
Pat Isserie very proud.
[Matt] Who's Pat Isserie?
He's a plumber from Bolton.
He loves this show.
[Matt] Oh, that's nice!
Hi, Pat, if you're watching.
You have three hours.
-On your marks.
-Get set.
[sing-song] Bake!
[Giuseppe] The judges are expecting
flawless, patisserie-style slices.
They must have been looking for words
that would scare the hell out of us.
[Chigs] You can't afford to make
any mistakes in any part,
and I make a lot of mistakes. [chuckles]
[Prue] I love Patisserie Week
because it gives the bakers a chance
to show how skilful they can be.
[Jürgen] Going on for the semi-final.
Going to measure ingredients precisely
and not lose track of what I'm doing.
We're asking
for eight identical layered slices.
I think there's going
to be nine layers in total.
We want those lines to be visible,
clear and absolutely impeccable.
This is all about finesse.
Exquisite flavours.
[Crystelle] This is my yuzu curd.
It's a kind of cross between
a grapefruit and a lemon.
It is a bit of a risk.
[Paul] The four bakers,
they've all had a handshake,
and they've all been
Star Baker at least once.
So, we do have the best of the best
in the tent at the moment.
-[Paul] Hello, Crystelle.
-[Crystelle] Good morning.
Crystelle, tell us about
your Signature slices.
It's got coconut
and black sesame dacquoise,
a yuzu curd,
black sesame and almond Joconde,
and a white chocolate and coconut
Italian meringue buttercream,
and those layers are repeated.
Then a layer
of white chocolate ganache
piped with whipped cream.
-Very simple.
-Very, very simple. [chuckles]
[Matt] Crystelle is going way beyond
the three layers demanded by the brief.
She'll use sesame to flavour
not just her four layers of sponge,
but a caramel brittle
that sits on piped Chantilly cream,
designed to help balance
the sharp yuzu curd.
[Noel] You're one step from the final.
You have to think about that
but you have to put that
right out of your mind.
I don't want to feel pressure.
I want to bake and enjoy it.
What else do you want? World peace?
-And a full-body massage.
-World peace, er,
-an end to the pandemic.
-[laughs]
That's an absolute lie.
You want this so bad,
it's eating you up inside.
-Well… [laughs]
-Anyway, good luck. Bye-bye.
[Matt] All of the bakers are including
a whisked sponge called a Joconde.
[Chigs] A Joconde is just
with egg whites and a bit of fat.
And some sort of nut put through it,
so you could have almond or pistachio.
[Crystelle] There is no leavening agent,
so you wanna make sure you put enough air
into both your whites and your yolks.
[Giuseppe] This looks perfect to me.
[Chigs] This now has
the flour and almonds.
You just want to be gentle, but quick.
If you're too rough, it won't rise,
'cause you knock all the air out.
This is going in the oven immediately.
[Jürgen] It's a very thin sponge,
so it cooks very quickly.
[oven beeps]
And in my notes it says, "Watch."
Big mistake! Big mistake!
Big mistake!
[utensil clattering]
-Giuseppe, good morning.
-Good morning, guys.
[Paul] What have you done here?
I just put my batter
into the oven for baking,
and realised the flour is here. [chuckles]
-[both chuckling]
-Well, at least you realised before.
-Phew!
-Tell us all about your layered slice.
My layered slice
is inspired to a quintessential
Italian cake which is tiramisu.
Bravo!
[Matt] Giuseppe's giving his tiramisu
slice a twist with a layer of sultanas
stewed in Marsala wine between
the traditional coffee-soaked sponges,
and mascarpone pâté à bombe.
He'll be hoping no other
ingredients are forgotten.
[exclaims]
How can you possibly forget
to add flour to your batter?
This is the tension playing tricks on me.
[Matt] At least Giuseppe only has
one sponge to contend with.
I'm toasting my desiccated coconut
before I add it to my dacquoise.
[Matt] Crystelle
is making life doubly difficult,
incorporating a second baked layer
to her slices.
Once I've got the baked elements
and the buttercreams and curds done,
it's then a case of assembly.
Now, I'm doing a billion things at once.
Happens to me all the time, man.
[Jürgen] You're coming out.
Good texture.
[Chigs] Five more minutes.
I'm gonna overbake it a bit
because I'm gonna soak it in syrup,
so it can hold its integrity.
I am making
a raspberry and chocolate slice.
I want to make sure the flavour
of the raspberry comes across
more than the chocolate,
'cause chocolate can be overpowering,
but I want that raspberry
to punch them round the face.
[Noel] With a slender layer
of chocolate ganache
sandwiched between Joconde sponges,
supporting a raspberry mousse,
thin coating of raspberry jelly,
and delicate decorations,
Chigs' slices will be the epitome
of Parisian elegance.
Over the weeks,
you've got better in your finesse.
-This should play to your new strengths--
-Fingers crossed.
If you want to get through to the final,
only one person can do that.
Just me. I know.
-Good luck.
-Thank you, guys. Appreciate it.
-Cheers, Matt.
That meant a lot, that they've
noticed my finishing is getting better.
But the pressure's there definitely now.
I can't get him saying that, and then me
make an absolute mess of this.
[Jürgen grunts] It's called
"Murder at the Opera."
A variation of the opera cake.
[Matt] Chigs isn't the only baker
with a blood-red theme to his slices.
[Jürgen] My wife came up with the name.
She tasted the beetroot,
thought it was crazy,
er, but then really liked it.
[Matt] Jürgen's opera cake-style slices
will feature two buttercreams,
beetroot and cassis,
separated by coffee liqueur-soaked
Joconde layers,
coated in a chocolate glaze
and pierced by tuile daggers.
[Jürgen] I like the opera.
Probably my most favourite
is Alban Berg's Wozzeck
because it's multi-layered.
It has a lot of hidden things,
bit like my bakes. [laughs]
[Crystelle] Gonna take out these bad boys.
It's got a nice crust, which is good
because it will stop it from going soggy.
-[Giuseppe exhales]
-Gonna get my mousse on the go.
How long we got left now?
[Noel] Hey, Matt.
Can my friend do the time call?
-Sure.
-Introducing Sharky Sharkerson.
You ready, Sharky?
This is your big moment.
They'll do what you gotta say, go!
[Matt mimicking Sharky] Hello, bakers.
You're halfway through the challenge.
By the way, I'd like to say,
sharks get a very bad rap.
[Noel] All right, that's enough.
Unbelievable. I told him to
stick to the script and project.
Bakers, you're halfway through.
[Matt] In classic patisserie style,
the judges are expecting silky-smooth
soft-set elements
to complement the sponge layers.
My meringue is turning into
meringue buttercream,
'cause I'm throwing in
lots and lots of butter.
[Matt] Three of the bakers are making
meringue-based creams…
A pâté à bombe is Italian meringue
made with yolks rather than whites.
[Matt] …that require heating
to pasteurise the eggs.
-How do you know when that's done?
-When it's at 60 degrees.
-[mixer whirring]
-Forty-five.
Fifteen to go!
This is television.
[Matt] It's a time-consuming step
that Chigs has decided to avoid.
[Chigs] In the mousse, I've got
raspberry puree, sugar and gelatin leaves,
and whipping cream.
[Matt] And he's already started
constructing his layers.
[Chigs] It'll go in the freezer
for the initial chill. I'll take it out,
put my jelly on it, leave it in
the fridge for half an hour, 40 minutes.
De-mould it, cut it, decorate it.
That's it. Finished.
That's gonna go in the freezer now.
-Fifty-two, 53--
-[groans]
Excruciating.
[Giuseppe] I'm blending
the mascarpone cream
into the pâté à bombe.
I feel like we did that together.
I hope we get to the final.
-Yes.
-We're now a baking duo, right?
-We're a baking duo, yes.
-[Noel] Like Batman and Robin.
I feel like you're Batman
and I'm definitely Robin.
[chuckles]
Yeah, that's good.
I'm dividing up the buttercream
to flavour it.
Beetroot pulp.
I'm murdering my buttercream.
[Giuseppe] Time is getting tight.
The cooling down of the elements
is holding me back.
-[Matt] What's going on in there?
-That is sultanas drying out.
It doesn't look appealing at the moment.
Yes, a bit like a poo-ey porridge
at the moment.
[chuckles] I didn't
want to say that but…
-Well, I didn't.
-…that''s-- Oh, okay.
[Noel] While the rest of the bakers
start to assemble their layers…
[Crystelle] Oh, God!
…Chigs is already working
on his finishing touches.
That's about a millimetre,
maybe two millimetres, of jelly,
so that should set pretty quickly.
I'm not gonna lie,
I will be gutted if I got kicked out now.
If it's rubbery,
or the ganache is too thick,
the sponge isn't cooked properly,
then you're out, pretty much.
Bakers, you have half an hour left.
-[Giuseppe] You're done?
-[Chigs] I've got to decorate it.
-I have to wait for this.
-How long is the chilling time?
[breathes deeply] As long as I can get.
[Crystelle] Just need to be careful here.
Yeah, boy.
Right. Freezer.
The sultanas are not as cold
as I'd like them to be.
But I can't wait.
It smells really good.
I'm looking forward to try this one.
[Crystelle] These are
the little decorations to go on top.
Caramel and sesame seeds.
[Noel] It's ridiculous when you think
about this in the cold light of day.
A man making chocolate triangles
to impress an orange man
with very blue eyes.
-Think about that, let that sink in.
-[grunts] Fair enough.
[laughs]
[Jürgen] This is tuile paste.
We don't know what the murder is,
we just have the evidence
as blood and dagger.
I'm gonna need ten minutes
to do the final assembly,
so can you give me the ten minutes call?
[Jürgen] Going in.
And I really have to watch that.
It's so easy to burn.
I wanna get it out.
Bakers, you have ten minutes left.
This is very close.
[Matt] The bakers have been told
to ensure their slices are identical.
[Chigs] Going well so far.
I think that one's going
well-er than that one.
Yeah, this bit here…
These are the things they'll pick up on.
It's making me angry thinking
about them picking up on that.
If they do pick up on that,
I'll sweep Paul's legs.
-Like I'm in Cobra Kai.
-[laughs]
[Crystelle] It's cutting okay.
Oh, God! I feel like I'm giving birth.
Sorry, not that I've ever done
that before. [laughs]
[gasps]
Now is the main bit, just wanna make sure
they're all the same size.
[Crystelle] Commit to the cut.
Oh, yes.
Come on, cack-handed Lil, you can do this.
[chuckles]
[Chigs] Look at that one.
That's a good one, innit? [chuckles]
[Giuseppe] This should be fine.
I'm shaking.
You have one minute left!
[Chigs] I can't stop shaking.
It should go like that.
[Chigs exclaims]
[Jürgen] The buttercream
isn't as set as I wanted.
And they're not exactly the same size.
The more I look at them,
the more I'm not happy with them.
Neat enough, I think. [chuckles]
Bakers, your time is up!
Yeah, just a second.
Please place your slices
at the end of your stations.
-[exhales]
-[chuckling] You all right?
Mamma mia!
[Matt] The bakers' layered slices
are ready to be judged
by Prue and Paul.
-Chigs.
-Hi.
-[Prue] It looks good, Chigs.
-[Chigs] Thank you.
I like them a lot. You've managed
to create nice, sharp lines.
-Very Parisian.
-[Prue] Making my mouth water.
Erm, I like the sponge in there.
The sponge is good.
I think you've got just enough chocolate
there to marry it with the raspberry.
-Mmm.
-[Chigs] Are you serious?
-[Paul] Absolutely.
-[bakers clapping]
[Chigs] Thank you.
[Prue] I was a bit nervous
because that chocolate is quite strong.
Then I took it with the raspberry,
and it's perfect.
-[Paul] Yeah.
-So, that was all right, then.
-Well done.
-Thank you very much.
-Thank you, Chigs.
-Thank you, guys.
-[whispering] Not bad.
-[Chigs] Thank you.
Very nice, Jürgen.
The layers look stark, sharp.
The daggers make it,
'cause it does look very different
from a traditional opera cake.
[Prue] Thank you.
I think that's sensational.
-Thank you.
-The textures are absolutely perfect.
I like it, but I don't love it.
The flavour I do get is coffee.
And a bit of chocolate.
I cannot taste anything else.
Beetroot will bring colour and sweetness,
but it won't bring flavour.
Textures are spot-on, though,
I'll give you that.
Pity I'm not the one
who hands out handshakes.
-Thank you.
-I'll give you two.
[Prue] They're very unusual.
Really striking.
-[Noel] Exotic caterpillar colours.
-That's exactly what I was going for.
-[chuckles]
-[Noel] I hope so.
It's quite an unusual texture
because the dacquoise is really chewy.
[Paul] Yuzu is such a beautiful flavour.
But then you're left with the sesame
and that gorgeous texture of the creams
and the sponges going through there.
Oh, my God. [exclaims]
-Well done.
-[bakers clapping]
[Prue] Crystelle, that's absolutely
deserved because it's very striking.
It's absolutely delicious.
It's a little bit of genius.
[Paul] I've never had
anything like that before.
-Well done.
-Thank you so much.
-Thank you.
-Well done.
-What's happening to my life?
-You haven't woken up yet.
-This is a dream.
-[Crystelle] Yeah. [sighs]
It's really very elegant,
and looks very stylish.
Because the Joconde is soaked,
it's so soft.
-It's just delicious.
-It is.
[Prue laughing]
-How annoying is that?
-[contestants applaud]
The masala wine in there,
and the stewed sultanas
gives that little bit of body to it.
Sorry, I don't understand
anything you're saying.
-I'm just trying to fight back…
-[all laughing]
I don't think I've ever had an afternoon
in the tent as satisfactory as this one.
-Wow.
-[Noel] Three handshakes!
-Excellent.
-You're gonna have to retire. [chuckles]
-Well done, mate. Amazing.
-Thank you.
-[Paul] Sorry, Jürgen.
-You got a handshake from me, all right?
I'd have given you one.
Okay.
[Giuseppe] Going from, "My slices
don't look as polished
as I would have liked them to be,"
to handshake, I was ecstatic.
[Crystelle] Well,
when he took out his hand,
I just thought of my family
jumping for joy
because I literally told them yesterday,
"This isn't going to be my week."
And they went, "Crystelle, be positive."
So I'm kind of being positive
for them, really.
And I'm really happy.
As a collective, we've done really well.
[Chigs] Don't mean nothing today,
handshake don't mean anything.
Just giving them out willy-nilly.
[Jürgen] There were three handshakes
in the tent. I didn't get one.
The judges were divided.
Bottom line, I'm in trouble now.
[Matt] For the bakers, the pressure
of Patisserie Week is about to rise
as they face their toughest Technical yet.
[Noel] Hello, bakers.
Welcome back to the tent.
It's time for your Technical Challenge,
which today has been set for you
by the adorable Prue.
-Prue, ay words of wisdom?
-Yes. Use your time wisely.
And remember that setting and chilling
are really important.
As ever, the Technical Challenge
will be judged blind.
So we're gonna have to ask
these two to leave the tent.
Bye-bye.
Where do you think they're going?
[Noel] Prue's taking Paul to a safari park
so he can be released
back in with the gorillas.
Oh. Yes, I heard about
the new silverback breeding programme.
That's great.
Now, for your Technical Challenge,
Prue would love you
to make a sablé breton tart.
Your tart should consist
of a sablé breton pastry
topped with raspberry confiture
and piped pistachio crème mousseline.
It must be filled with fresh berries
and decorated with gilded meringue kisses
and chocolate curls.
[Matt] You have two hours and 45 minutes.
On your marks.
-Get set.
-Bake.
Ay, caramba. Look at all this stuff.
[Jürgen] I've heard of sablé breton.
I think, essentially,
we know what we're doing.
I ain't got a clue what's going on.
I don't know anything they said
besides pistachio and fruit.
Semi finals, then, Prue,
and you've chosen a sablé breton tart.
-It's quite complicated, isn't it?
-It is.
[Prue] They have to do
quite a lot of things.
They've got to make a sablé breton bottom,
which is a very thick biscuit.
And then there's a thin layer
of raspberry confiture,
French for jam.
And then mousseline
flavoured with pistachio.
Then the raspberries and strawberries,
meringue kisses,
and curls of tempered chocolate.
So where could they go wrong with this?
They might not understand
that this thing doesn't have sides.
They just cut the pastry out,
plonk it in the tin to get that nice edge.
Right. That could catch them out.
And they have to watch
their setting and chilling.
That crème mousseline
really has to be thick enough
not to run down the sides,
but soft enough to get the perfect shape.
It almost looks like a sponge.
[Paul] It does.
[Prue] It's buttery and light
like a shortbread.
-Not as sweet as a shortbread.
-No.
It's gorgeous.
The French know what they're doing.
-[Prue] I know.
-Aren't they annoying?
I do like the mousseline,
the texture's lovely, it's nice and light.
I'm not sure how the bakers
are going to deal with this.
From the sablé to the mousseline,
will they be able
to get their timings right? I don't know.
But it is the semi final.
We know they're very good.
So, let's go and see.
So, I'm starting with the sablé dough,
'cause that needs to chill.
The first step is,
"Whisk the egg yolks and caster sugar."
"Add softened butter,
and then the dry ingredients."
This is fancy butter,
it's Brittany butter.
I suppose that's what makes
this breton tart a breton tart.
I'm just adding the dry ingredients.
I think the key here
is just not to overwork the dough
like any shortcrust.
[Jürgen] I do it by hand
because I can be gentler than the machine.
I want to keep the dough very short.
[Chigs] That's the dough done, I think.
Now, it says "chill." I don't know
if I should freeze or fridge it.
I think I'm gonna put it in the fridge.
It says "chill," not freeze, so…
-Okay. Oh.
-[tray clatters]
Right. That's step one done.
-[Noel] Hello.
-[Jürgen] Hi, Noel.
Well, I just thought that was wrong.
Everyone getting a handshake
except for Jürgy-pops.
But I feel like you're strong enough…
-I should be--
-…to rise from the ashes.
I should be able to.
[Noel] I just thought I'd check in,
see if you're all right.
You seem fine.
You're not going to get caught up
in all the hysteria, are you?
-[speaking indistinctly]
-It's not your style.
-You're the jazz baker.
-Hmm.
Just probably go back
and play some Miles Davis
on your trombone, right?
-Something like that.
-You, silhouetted against the moon--
-I'm gonna get some raspberries.
-Okay, bye-bye.
Sablé done. For meringue kisses,
make meringue.
Okay, so one medium egg white.
Probably should've used a smaller bowl.
[Crystelle chuckles]
How is this looking?
Still really runny.
I don't know if I'm doing this right.
[exclaims]
Looks done.
I might start again.
I just feel like that's not looking
like what a meringue should look like.
[Giuseppe] I'm making these very small,
'cause the smaller they are,
the quicker they will be to bake.
Is there a piping nozzle here?
Have they given us a nozzle?
Nope.
[Crystelle] This looks more like
the meringue we know and love.
[Chigs] Can't fit any more on.
Let's go.
These are gonna take about--
I don't know. I'll have to keep checking.
Okay, meringue kisses are done.
Right. Make the raspberry confiture.
Oh, it's a piping nozzle
to make the meringue kisses.
Now they're in the oven,
I can't do anything about it.
All right. Step number three,
we make the raspberry confiture.
Raspberry confiture.
Am I saying that right? "Confiture."
Raspberries, jam sugar and pectin.
That's just jam. Right?
Confiture is like a jam,
but it's got bits of fruit.
It's a bit more rustic.
Right, okay.
"Make pistachio paste and use--"
What?
"Use to make pistachio crème mousseline."
Crème mousselini. Right. Erm--
[Jürgen] Crème mousseline is crème pat,
with additional butter.
I've got my egg yolks,
flour and sugar here.
And I'm just tempering this
with vanilla-infused milk.
This is done.
While it's still warm,
I think I put the butter in.
Just going to make sure
that butter all melts into there.
-Hey, Matt, how's it going? Good?
-Good, thanks.
-How's it going for you?
-Yeah, all right.
I'm making some sort of crème mousseline.
Named after the, er,
Italian dictator Mussolini.
But that's what I thought,
it was called crème Mussolini.
-They said, "No, Chigs, that's wrong."
-Yeah.
How'd you feel about the handshake?
Yeah, it was good. I was happy. And then--
-[Matt] Everyone else got one.
-[Chigs] Crystelle got one.
And then he got one.
That's extraordinary. I don't think
that's ever happened in the tent.
-Never?
-I don't think so.
-I don't watch this show.
-[laughs]
I watch the other side.
[Chigs laughing] Good.
I'm assuming that's the right stage
to add the pistachio paste.
Now, it doesn't say how much to put in.
[Jürgen] I added my pistachios
to the crème mousseline.
-That is looking good.
-[Chigs] Whack it all in.
They want pistachio taste,
I'll give them pistachio.
[Giuseppe] Looks good to me.
Certainly green.
Mmm, oh! Tastes really pistachio-y.
[Chigs] Just needs to chill now.
I'll pop this in the fridge.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
Approaching one hour
that the meringue kisses
have been in the oven.
Gonna take them out.
I don't want them to brown.
Ah, there we go. They're done.
[Giuseppe] They're perfectly baked.
They, er, look good.
It's not really French patisserie, is it,
that colour?
They're not supposed to be
brown like that.
-Oh, my God, look at Jürgen's. Perfect.
-[Jürgen] I'm happy with them. Next step.
"Roll and cut the sablé dough
to fit the tin."
[Chigs] I'm assuming this dough
is gonna have to be really thin.
Just trying to gauge
if the tart needs sides.
It just says, "Roll out the sablé dough
and fit it in the tin."
I just don't know if
it's supposed to be a sideless pastry.
I just don't know.
Do you go up the sides?
Or just put it in the bottom?
Sablé breton is usually baked
as a thick layer,
as far as I remember.
I'm not gonna do the sides.
I'm gonna roll it out
so it just fits the circle.
Right.
This dough melts literally in your hands.
Right. We're in.
[Jürgen] I expect that
to bake for 25 minutes.
I'm gonna say, this thickness,
about 20 minutes.
So I'm gonna be heating this
at least 20 minutes.
Okay, I hope
that was the right thing to do.
-But it's in now.
-[Chigs] What was I gonna do now?
Er, chocolate.
"For chocolate decorations,
using the acetate rectangles,
the long edge of the chocolate cone,
and narrow glass to make chocolate curls."
Oh, tempering chocolate.
I can do that that.
Right. That needs to melt.
This is the bit. This is the magic.
Watch this.
Little prayer to the chocolate god.
Please!
-And I'm not gonna touch it.
-Please make me good.
I don't want the wrath of Paul Hollywood.
Look at that. Boom.
-Well for now, so good so far.
-[Noel smacks lips]
Give me a shout
when you're gonna put that in there
'cause I want to see that.
-[Chigs] Come on.
-[Crystelle] That looks okay, actually.
-[Noel] What the hell?
-[Giuseppe] Look at that.
You were supposed to call me back.
We had a deal, an agreement.
-Sorry. I'm multitasking already.
-You forgot me, didn't you?
-What do you think?
-Yeah, I liked it.
But I'd have liked it more
if you'd have let me watch.
It's had 20 minutes. Yeah.
[Crystelle groans] Oh, man.
The sides have collapsed in.
Quite frankly,
that is not patisserie standard.
[Jürgen] I think it's looking good.
It needs to be golden,
like a nice shortbread.
Right. Do I stick this in the freezer?
'Cause it needs to chill.
I want to cool this very quickly
so that I can put the fillings
and the decorations on it.
Bakers, you have 15 minutes left.
"To assemble, spread remaining
confiture over the sablé base…"
"…leaving a one-centimetre pastry border."
[Giuseppe] This looks delicious.
[Chigs] Just a massive
Jammie Dodger, innit?
"Pipe the pistachio crème mousseline
over the confiture and chill."
[Chigs] All right, I'm gonna wait
because this has not set yet.
[Giuseppe] Ooh. It's very thick.
[Crystelle] So I'm gonna do
just big fat stars.
[sighs]
[Giuseppe exclaims] Oh, careful.
Right. I need to chill this again.
How long do we have?
Bakers, you have five minutes left.
I don't think I have time.
I should just start assembling.
Now the question is,
should I go for a pattern?
I think it should be
a fairly random arrangement.
I'll go for a pattern.
My crème pat's not setting.
I'll just put it on.
Nothing I can do about it.
[Chigs] Ah, I'm losing all the definition.
It's turning into liquid.
There you go. Now it's time to glaze this.
[Crystelle] Surely that's enough
strawberries for that tiny little tart.
Nah, it's just not set.
Everything's just oozing back out.
This needs to go in the fridge again.
[Giuseppe] Meringues. Let's get gilding.
[Jürgen] This is gold leaf.
[Chigs] Look, I'm shrinking.
Can you see I'm shrinking?
Oh, this is going from bad to worse.
Bakers, you have one minute left.
[Chigs laughing] It looks a mess.
I can do this. I can do this.
[Chigs] This doesn't
look like French patisserie.
Do I pipe more?
Maybe I'll just do a little.
Bakers, your time is up.
[sighs] That's it.
Oh, my God, I don't even think
my local corner shop would sell this.
Please bring your bakes to the table
and place them behind your photograph.
[Noel] Prue and Paul
are looking for patisserie perfection.
Each sablé breton should have
a thick, crumbly base
topped with raspberry confiture
and beautifully set
pistachio crème mousseline,
elegantly decorated with fruit,
gilded meringue kisses
and chocolate curls.
-They all look very different.
-Hmm.
This one looks pretty.
But the base is very, very thin.
-[Prue] Should be much thicker than that.
-Yeah.
[Prue] The baker's tried to make it
like a conventional tart.
-Not flat.
-Yeah.
Where's the rest of the
strawberries and raspberries?
It's a little bit dense on the biscuit,
but it does taste quite nice.
Moving on. From the mousseline upwards,
that looks good.
But that base is very, very thin.
[Prue] That looks a bit overbaked.
[Paul] Let's have a look.
I think it is slightly overbaked.
[Prue] Actually, it tastes quite good.
Everything else is good.
I'm just not happy with that biscuit.
The mousseline on this
is terrible on number three.
And those meringue kisses
are not well piped.
And that mousseline
has not set at all has it?
This is not a proper biscuit base,
it's a bit soft.
-Hmm. It's underbaked.
-Mmm.
[Prue] Not helped by very wet mousseline,
which will make it soggy anyway.
-[Paul] Hmm.
-[Prue] Okay.
This is very pretty.
And it has got small
little Italian kisses.
I'd like to see
more of a dome of the fruit.
And inside…
very thin.
I think the baker's tried to make it
like a conventional flan.
-Flavour's good.
-[Paul] Hmm.
Okay.
[Matt] Prue and Paul will now rank
the sablé breton from worst to best.
All right, in last place is this one.
Chigs, underbaked, mousseline is not set.
But besides that, it's fine.
Cheers.
In third place, we have this one.
Crystelle, the biscuit is a little thin,
but the flavour's nice.
In second, we have this one.
-Whose is this?
-That's me.
Giuseppe, the sablé was far too thin,
but the overall appearance was quite nice.
Which means, Jürgen, the biscuit base
is a fraction overbaked,
-but otherwise it's a very good sablé.
-[bakers clapping]
-Thank you.
-[Crystelle] Well done.
[Jürgen chuckling]
That went very well.
What a relief.
I certainly will sleep better tonight.
Second last is not great.
But I just didn't want to come last
because that would have put me
in a really scary position.
[Chigs] The Technical was a disaster.
That's probably my worst bake.
Out of the 26 bakes we've done,
that's my worst one.
Very, very happy.
Second position. Fantastic.
The first day was very positive,
which is a good position
to start the second day.
The Showstopper of patisserie
is very difficult.
Er, I expect a very tense day tomorrow.
[Chigs] I do better
with my back against the wall,
so I'll come out swinging tomorrow.
[Matt] There's just
the Showstopper Challenge left
before Prue and Paul will decide
who will be crowned Star Baker
and who'll miss out
on a place in the final.
[sighs] Okay.
Hello, bakers, welcome back to the tent.
It's time for your Showstopper Challenge.
Yes, the judges would like you to create
a spectacular themed banquet display,
comprising of at least
12 individual entremets desserts,
arranged around a beautifully
crafted edible centrepiece.
You have five hours
for your entremets desserts.
Minus the three and a half hours
that me and Matt come 'round
and witter in your ear
about any old nonsense.
-Yeah, sorry about that.
-[Noel] On your marks.
-Get set.
-Bake!
Getting into my zone.
Feeling confident to pull this off.
I'm ready to fight and do my best
and enjoy it, most importantly.
[Paul] It's Showstopper time,
and we've asked the bakers
to produce a themed entremet display.
Now, this is going to be
one of the most difficult challenges
they've ever done in the tent.
I didn't know
what a flipping entremet was.
[mumbles] entremet.
This is not normal stuff.
[Paul] An entremet is a delicate dessert.
It's layer upon layer
of beautiful textures and flavours.
What I'm looking for more than anything
is finesse.
When you cut into them, they must look
absolutely staggeringly pretty.
We're certainly stepping
outside of the home baking skills here.
It's very complex, gonna be a long day.
The bakers do have five hours,
but this is the semi finals
so we want to see what they can do.
The more skills they can show us
in this banquet display, the better.
Oh! Need to stop doing that to myself.
[Paul] There are a few bakers
fighting for their place in the final.
And I can't call who's gonna go through.
But it's gonna be interesting.
-[Paul] Giuseppe, hello.
-Buongiorno.
Tell us all about your entremet display.
So, my display's gonna be inspired
by a city that I've lived in
for about ten years in Tuscany.
That's Pisa.
So, the centrepiece is gonna be
a representation
that requires some imagination
of the Leaning Tower.
[Matt] Giuseppe
will fashion his leaning tower
from puffed rice and marshmallow
while his domed entremet will feature
a chocolate custard and cherry insert
surrounded by pine nut bavarois.
-That all sounds very Tuscan.
-It does. Sounds delicious.
-That was the plan.
-And have you practised this?
Er, if I'm honest, start to finish? No.
So if it comes out wonky,
I got a justification.
[all chuckling]
[Jürgen] Making a raspberry pulp.
This is the basis for my raspberry jelly
as well as the raspberry Bavarian.
[Noel] Jürgen, too, has been inspired
by his love of architecture.
My bake is the Torii gate in the sea.
It's a Japanese gate.
Typically, they are
at the entrance to Shinto temples.
And when I was young,
I got a children's, er, encyclopaedia.
One picture in there
that particularly fascinated me
was a picture
of this Japanese temple gate.
[Noel] Jürgen will construct
his Torii gate from gingerbread
whilst a fleet of Japanese entremets boats
will contain layers of genoise sponge,
raspberry jelly and no less
than three Bavarian creams,
white chocolate, raspberry and matcha.
I occasionally love matcha,
but mostly it's too strong for me.
It can be an acquired taste,
but I find when you activate the matcha,
you need to heat it to about
80 degrees in some liquid.
Does that make it milder?
It makes it milder.
It takes the grassy flavour away.
[Paul] Your flavour combinations
are normally very good.
It's a very original idea. Lovely.
-Thank you.
-Sounds amazing, good luck, Jürgen.
[Matt] At five hours,
this is the longest challenge
the bakers have faced so far.
I've got a lot to do today.
[Crystelle] Entremets are about
multitasking until you almost faint.
[Jürgen] I'm building
the Bavarian inserts.
The insert is the first thing
that I have to start making,
'cause that needs to freeze
before I can start
working on anything else around it.
-Next.
-Pine nut bavarois.
[Matt] Not only
must every flavour pack a punch…
[Giuseppe] Roasting them
releases a lot of flavour.
This little bunch of pine nuts
is flavouring 12 entremets.
…they must also work together
in perfect harmony.
[Jürgen] This is matcha powder.
I need to make the matcha Bavarian.
Matcha flavour shouldn't be overly strong,
but it should balance
the tartness of the raspberries.
[Matt] But that's not all.
I've added four sheets of gelatin.
[Matt] When it comes to textures,
patisserie demands perfection.
[Giuseppe] The texture of Bavarois
is very difficult to get right
because it needs to be very soft.
But it's very easy
to overdo the gelatin element
and get it too thick and rubbery.
Okay.
[Matt] And, with a place
in the final at stake…
I am doing vanilla and coconut
cremeux centres.
…Crystelle's taking no chances.
When in practice I did them, they set,
but I was worried they set a bit too much.
I'm going to do
two almost-identical batches,
but one has just got
one less sheet of gelatin.
[Matt] Crystelle's vanilla
and coconut cremeux centres
will be encased by mango bavarois
and a punchy passion fruit jelly.
Her tropical entremets
will surround a wedding-themed centrepiece
dedicated to sister Chantelle,
whose nuptials
have been sadly paused by the pandemic.
-What are you making?
-This is a Swiss meringue.
I'm doing a little meringue flower arch.
-Real arch, can you get under it?
-Er, yeah.
-Can you limbo under it?
-If you limbo really far down.
You look like you're dressed to limbo.
Yeah, I actually once
won a limbo competition on holiday.
-I'm deadly serious. Of course I did.
-Of course you did.
I feel like I might have
limboed at a party
-and was quite good at it.
-Really?
We should do a limbo-off.
[chuckling] If you get-- If you get
to the final, we'll do a limbo-off.
Oh, well, that's not gonna happen.
I mean, yeah, yeah.
Deal.
-[Paul] Hi, Chigs.
-Hey, Paul. Hi.
[Matt] Crystelle's not the only baker
putting family at the heart
of their entremets display.
My Showstopper is called, "The Apple
Doesn't Fall Far from the Tree."
It's based around an apple tree
my grandparents had in their garden.
We used to play around it as kids.
So my centrepiece
is going to be in the shape of a tree.
[Matt] Nestled under
his cinnamon-biscuit apple tree,
Chigs' entremets will be filled
with a caramelised apple insert,
caramel and white chocolate mousse,
and coated in a dark chocolate shell
and shiny red mirror glaze.
This has never worked for me in practice.
Don't say that in front of the judges.
Why would you do it then?
It hasn't worked because when I set
the chocolate around it,
I put a stick in it to dip it.
When I take
the stick out, it always cracks.
So, today, I've never tried it,
I'm gonna use toothpicks instead.
-Good luck, Chigs.
-Thank you, guys.
Do some praying.
I love that you're living on the edge.
You have to!
I have practised it,
it's just something's always gone wrong.
Today is the day
I need to pull it out the bag.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
I feel like
my legs are getting longer, no?
No.
[Chigs] All the elements are done now.
I've gotta get
the entremets in the freezer,
setting for as long as they can
so they hold their shape
when I take them out of the moulds.
The Joconde sponge is ready.
[sighs] That was close.
Mango bavarois is here.
I'm gonna fill these.
Then put my cremeux inserts inside.
I put the apple pie insert in
and I'm topping up with some more mouse.
The cherry's a perfect colour for this.
It gives it a nice burst of flavour.
Just in the centre and it's very chewy.
The whole thing is very soft
so you need something with more bite.
[Crystelle] These seem
a little bit wobbly, but--
Oh! [gasps] They're set.
[Jürgen] This is genoise sponge.
I need to set the jelly
on top of this this sponge
before I can get the entremets built.
[Crystelle gasps] Freeze baby, freeze.
[Jürgen] Jelly's in.
-Right. Done.
-Biscuit.
Preparing the dough for my centrepiece.
It's gingerbread.
It is wonderful dough to work with.
[Chigs] This is a simple cinnamon biscuit.
I'm gonna bake it for a bit longer
so it's crispier and snappier as well.
I don't want it
to be like gingerbread, where it's soft.
[Noel] And while Jürgen's
intricate Japanese Temple gate
requires batch-baking
nearly 40 individual pieces of biscuit…
[Jürgen] Going in for ten. [gasps]
I'll do this thing again.
…Chigs' time-saving tree design…
-[Chigs] The template for the biscuit.
-…consists of just two pieces.
[Chigs] Twenty minutes.
[Noel] But Giuseppe
and Crystelle's centrepiece…
I'm making my big edible wreath.
…requires no oven time at all.
This is puffed rice,
the bricks and mortar of my leaning tower.
[Crystelle] Puffed rice is very light,
so it's a good option
for constructing things.
It's not heavy, so it shouldn't collapse.
[Noel] With his first batch
of gingerbread in the oven
and jelly layers set…
Okay, here we go.
…for Jürgen, entremet assembly
can finally begin.
I'm very slightly behind.
I need to get the entremets frozen,
otherwise they just stick
to the mould and crumble.
-What're you doing?
-Hello. I am smoothing down a candle.
So, how's your bake going?
Have these been baked yet?
They have been baked.
They're little doves which are going
to go on top of my entremets.
I'm just putting the candle in the hole.
-Erm…
-So it's gone in the hole.
…and I'm just going to,
erm, smooth it down.
Oh, my Lord, I don't think
I can take much more of this.
Bakers, you have an hour left.
[Chigs] That's a good colour.
That's a great colour,
[Jürgen] Possibly a little bit overdone,
but better overdone in this one.
Nice and stable. That's the last lot.
Now I'm smoothing out the two logs.
This will be the main tower,
and that smaller one will be the top.
[Crystelle] This is Swiss meringue.
You put two different colours
in one piping bag
and out pops a little swirled beauty.
How are you, Jürgs? Nice colour.
-Wonderful, isn't it?
-[Noel] That is an intense red.
That's like hell.
Well, it's a gateway to something else.
-Gateway…
-[both] …to the final.
Is that what you're doing? Clever boy.
Might be. I don't want to put
the letters on the wall, so to speak.
I feel like you're building
your own metaphor.
[Jürgen] Indeed.
[Crystelle] If I overbake this,
this whole thing can crack.
So it's a very tricky thing
that I've decided to do for my structure.
[Chigs] We'll see how it fits.
Yeah, baby.
[screams] I hit it!
Don't worry, it's okay.
Just stick it together with icing.
I need to make sure the entremets set.
Need to take them out of the moulds.
They're completely frozen.
They're very well set, which is good.
They feel really soft,
and I don't know why,
but I'm just gonna have to go with it.
Oh, God.
Just stay calm Crystelle, stay calm.
[Jürgen] Okay.
Houston, we've got sails.
Assembly time, definitely.
This is isomalt.
I'm using it to stick
my Torii gate together.
[Crystelle] Doing a very abstract swirl.
Okay, I have to glaze my entremets.
[exhales] Breathe, woman. Okay.
Noel told me he thinks
you look like Robert De Niro.
-Can you do the impression?
-Which one?
[mimicking Robert De Niro]
You talking to me?
-Are you talking to me?
-Is that from Taxi Driver?
Yeah, that's Taxi Driver.
-Can you do that?
-I can't do the face.
-No.
-I can certainly do the--
-Yeah.
-Is it stuck?
Oh.
-Yeah. I'll go and get…
-[Chigs] Get it sorted out.
-Cheers. Thank you.
-Good luck with your bake.
[Giuseppe] The thickness of the glaze
is just right to cover everything.
Now I'm gonna dunk.
It still ain't perfect,
but it's the best I've ever had it.
[Jürgen] Engineering begins.
[Giuseppe] Going over it more than once.
I'm ruining this, jeez.
This is not going well.
-Jürgen. You all good?
-[sighs]
One piece is missing.
I'm sure I cut it out.
[breathing heavily]
Without this piece, it won't go up.
How much time?
Bakers, you have
half of an entire hour left.
[Jürgen] Oh,
this is going to be super tight.
This is just madness.
Just suddenly realised I have a lot to do
and really not a lot of time.
-[Jürgen] Yes. I'm happy with those.
-I've gotta quickly make some apple stems.
[Crystelle] So I'm doing pine cones,
roses, leaves, made out of butter cream.
They're coming out.
[Noel] That is the missing bit
slotting right in now. Yeah?
-Yeah.
-Yes! Jürgen.
[Chigs] It's not red enough,
it's gonna be a Pink Lady.
[Crystelle] Breathe, breathe, breathe.
[Crystelle gasps] Oh, for God's sake, no.
[Chigs sighs in frustration]
[Crystelle]
This is gonna be so tight. [sighs]
[Giuseppe] Never underestimate
an Italian engineer.
When it comes to make wonky buildings,
we're always first in the game.
[gasps]
Ooh…
[Jürgen] Going in for the glaze.
[Crystelle] Please don't crack.
[Jürgen] Oh, come on.
[Crystelle] I don't think
that's gonna stay.
It's gonna have to stay.
[sighs] Oh, God, please don't fall,
please don't fall.
Bakers, you have one minute left.
[sing-song] This is getting tight.
[Crystelle] Come on.
[Chigs] Ah, it's breaking.
Weddings are goddamn stressful.
Maybe it's a sign I shouldn't get married.
[sighs] I'm proper shaking.
Bakers, your time is up.
Please step away from your bakes.
[Jürgen sighs]
[winces]
-Well done.
-[Noel] Well done, kids.
-[sighs]
-That was a monster challenge.
[Matt] That was epic.
Look at Jürgen's, it's unbelievable.
[Giuseppe] Does it surprise you?
That was the most intense thing.
[Jürgen] I just want to say
well done to you all.
Yeah, guys, well done.
Do you know what? I'm proud of us.
[all chuckling]
[Crystelle] Yeah.
[Matt] It's judgement time for the bakers'
showstopping entremets displays.
Jürgen, would you like to bring up
your Showstopper, please?
Love the gate. It's very authentic.
The colour of the entremets
don't really draw you in.
It's a bit bland.
[Prue] This shape is perfect
for those little Japanese boats,
but if you'd had time, you could have
piped some detail on them
or something to have
made them stand out a bit more.
Hmm.
That's very interesting.
Different layers of taste,
one after another.
[Paul] Your raspberry jelly's
got a nice kick to it.
And that matcha
is hidden by the raspberry.
There's still a hint,
but the raspberry comes through.
You didn't want it the other way,
it would've been dry on the palate.
-Thank you.
-Well done.
Well done, Jürgen.
[Jürgen] Thank you.
Giuseppe, you said
you hadn't even practised this.
It's just amazing. It's leaning
more than the Leaning Tower of Pisa.
I think I made the leaning tower
wonkier than it is.
These look fairly straightforward
on the outside.
All the work, of course,
with an entremet, is on the inside.
-Yeah.
-[Paul] Oh, lovely.
-[Noel] Beautiful green.
-[Matt] Hmm.
[Prue] The bavarois is very delicious,
but the pine nut's
not coming through very well.
Oh, okay.
Without that cherry,
you really would be hunting for flavours.
Having said that,
all your textures are spot-on.
Thank you.
[Matt] Well done.
[Chigs] Well done, Giuseppe.
-It's very impressive.
-Thank you.
I'm knocked back by the purple colour.
They look more like a plums.
I should've put
more red colouring in the glaze.
-Pink ladies, that's what they are.
-Yeah, right.
I love that they're sitting on a biscuit.
And the biscuit looks well baked as well.
Hmm.
-It's exceptional.
-[chuckles nervously]
Your apple
has got a little tartness to it.
You can taste the caramel
in the bavarois as well.
And you have that slight
bitterness from the chocolate.
So you've got all the flavours
correctly balanced
to create an apple scene with the tree.
You've really been
on a journey, haven't you?
You started baking last year.
Look what you've done.
That is very, very, very good.
-[Chigs] Thank you, Paul.
-[Prue] Thanks, Chigs.
-Well done.
-Thank you very much.
[Noel] Well done, Chigs.
[Chigs exhales]
[Giuseppe, whispering]
Come on, you smashed it.
-That's stunning.
-[Prue] Love the colours.
If it was in the middle
of a wedding table,
all eyes would be upon it.
[Paul] What I'm interested in
is those entremets,
they look like works of arts.
[Prue] Mmm.
That, Crystelle, is flawless.
-[Paul] I don't know what I can say.
-It's just beautiful.
The passion fruit is really strong.
The mango much silkier. It is lovely.
-Absolutely lovely.
-Thank you. Sorry.
[Prue laughing]
-Thank you, Crystelle.
-Thank you so much.
[Matt] Well done.
Thank you so much.
[Crystelle] It's really emotional
because it always means more
to, erm, get good comments
on a bake that means a lot to you,
that's dedicated to someone. Erm,
[voice breaking]
so I'm just really proud of myself.
[sighs] I'm speechless at the moment
and a little taken aback
by the comments they've given me.
If I was to go out now,
I could walk out smiling.
I don't know how they're going to call it.
Yesterday, there were three handshakes
and I won the Technical.
And, today, all these
very positive comments.
There were four Star Bakers in there.
Simple as that.
[Giuseppe] We've become friends
over almost two months.
We are very proud of each other.
As a collective, we've done very well.
I don't know what's gonna happen.
It's a very, very close call.
[Matt] Wow. There are four really
impressive bakers in this tent.
I do not envy you the task
of having to separate them.
What's almost unique,
we're picking the worst of the best.
It really is difficult
because all of them tasted fantastic.
Crystelle.
Look at the layers in that.
The coconut biscuit.
-[Paul] The glaze is stunning.
-[Prue] Yes.
And Chigs, look
at the amount of skill in that.
There's a biscuit, a crumble.
There's a wonderful chocolate case,
which is not easy to do.
[Paul] Jürgen was clever
with the matcha and the raspberry.
-A bit boring to look at.
-And then you come down to Giuseppe.
My only complaint with this.
-I love the beautiful colour.
-So neat.
[Prue] And the cherry is fantastic.
My only complaint?
I couldn't taste the pine nut.
[Matt] So we're
in a very unusual position, where--
You could argue for any one of these.
This is the worst time to go home as well,
so it's horrible.
Yes, it is. It's really hard.
I don't know
how you're gonna make this decision.
[Noel] Ah, bakers,
this is such a precarious point
in the competition.
Obviously,
everyone wants to get to the final
and it's so close at this point,
it's just crazy.
I've got the amazing job
of announcing Star Baker.
The person who is Star Baker is…
Crystelle.
[Crystelle gasps]
-Oh, my God.
-[Chigs] Why are you surprised?
Why are you so surprised?
-Oh, my God.
-[Chigs] You just smashed it.
[Matt] Okay.
I'm afraid to say
that the person who will not
be making it into the final,
and who will be going home is…
Jürgen.
No.
[Crystelle] What?
[Giuseppe] What?
[Paul] Sorry, mate.
[Jürgen] I feel kind of okay,
I… I kind of saw it coming.
[laughs]
I think the others
are more shocked than I am.
[Crystelle] Oh, my gosh.
Jürgen, you've been
an inspiration, really.
-Like one of the most…
-Oh, Jürgen.
…incredible bakers ever.
You were amazing.
[voice breaking] It's been incredible.
It's been an absolute pleasure
to have you with us here.
Really enjoyed being here.
I made friends for life.
And I will be with them…
[chuckles] in… In spirit.
-See you in the final.
-[Crystelle] Thank you so much, Paul.
Erm…
shell-shocked is an understatement.
Hi, Star Baker.
It's just, I don't think
it's really hit me, really. It's mad.
Star Baker in Patisserie Week.
I'm in the final.
[voice breaking] Just a lot of things
that don't make sense.
[Noel, whispering]
You're in the final. [laugh]
I ain't got a clue what I'm doing here.
How has that happened?
I'm so shocked. I don't know what to say.
I am now cacking it. [laughs nervously]
I am scared sockless.
But I'm really, really--
Happy's not the right word,
I'm over the moon.
I just want to make the best out of it
and have a jolly good time next week.
Hi, is everyone there?
-[woman] Yeah.
-Erm, not good news.
You're not gonna see me for
another week because I got Star Baker!
-[laughs]
-[woman screaming]
[screaming continues]
[sniffling] I know, guys,
I'm in the final. [laughs]
[closing theme music playing]